Well, I don't want to spend a lot of time
on this follow up to the Jeffrey Epstein,
uh, a death, a suicide because there's so
much to cover.
But just as a, as a brief follow up, Donald
Trump retweeted a conspiracy theory about
Jeffrey Epstein linking it to the Clintons
from a guy claiming that Jeffrey Epstein had
info on Bill Clinton and Epstein was about
to release that Info and now the guy's dead.
I'm showing you a screenshot of this.
I'm not going to play the video.
I don't think there would be anything to gain,
so to speak, from playing the video.
Trump also retweeted from an account called
BNL live that is literally fake news.
I'm using that term the correct way.
I'm not using it the way Trump uses it to
describe any news he doesn't like or that
is negative about him.
Breaking documents were unsealed yesterday,
revealing that top Democrats, including Bill
Clinton, took private trips to Jeffrey Epstein's,
Pedophilia Island, the president of the United
States, either ignoring his own extensive
connections to Jeffrey Epstein or specifically
to distract from his own connections to Jeffrey
Epstein.
Re tweeting random conspiracy theorists and
fake news websites.
Is this the height of desperation to distract?
Is this merely the height of idiocy?
How are we to interpret this?
And of course I already told you the connections
that Epstein had to the Clintons.
He had 10 or 100 times the connections to
Trump a even being on video.
As I said, as I played for you a couple of
weeks ago, standing there with Jeffrey Epstein
of valuating the attractiveness of young girls,
which ones are hot, which ones are not quite
as hot.
So Trump advisor and all around terrible person.
Kellyanne Conway goes on Fox News over the
weekend and good for Fox was actually confronted
about Donald Trump re-tweeting this bottom
feeding pond, scum garbage.
And here's how she responded.
Why did the president than [inaudible] tweet
that Clinton suggestion?
I think the president just wants everything
to be investigated as you, as your report
or just revealed.
And just the day before, there was some unsealed
information implicating some people very high
up and I'm not going to repeat their names.
You already did that.
I'm not saying anything beyond that.
And I won't, but I will say it, Bill, that
there's always this rush too.
We need transparency.
We need accountability when it involves, um,
fictional accusations like collusion with
Russia to swing an election.
This seems to be very concrete in that Jeffrey
Epstein has done some very bad things over
a number of years.
And so let's continue to investigate that.
I don't think that somebody, um, crimes in
the accountability for that necessarily parishes
with them.
We know that the law, the law can allow for
many different investigations.
Maybe they are co-conspirators, may be, there
are not.
But again, it's an active investigation.
I think everybody should be at least relieved
when an general takes the action swiftly as
attorney general bar did yesterday.
Okay, let's, let's see where this terms by
this death and, and he's, and let's see where
it goes.
It's really new.
This all has within the last 24 to 28 hours
and we should go slow with this.
Just back on the retweet quickly, it's clear
what he was trying to say, wasn't it?
I think the present just wants everything
to be investigated and you know, they're trying
to connect the president to this monster from
years ago where they're seen dancing at a
video versus other people who were actively,
I suppose, flying around with this monster,
um, on his island, uh, which was known as
pedophilia island.
Perhaps there's a public interest in knowing
more about that.
Her explanation, Trump wants everything investigated
and Russia was a hoax and well maybe there
is something there between Epstein and Bill
Clinton.
Meanwhile, step back from us for, for just
a second from layer one of, was Epstein more
involved with Clinton or more involved with
Trump?
I think we know the answer to that.
We know about the joint allegations against
Trump and Epstein.
By a 13 year old, the Trump justice department
and William Barr are now going to be in charge
of the investigation into Epstein.
So do you think that that's going to lead
to anything implicating Trump laughable?
Of course it's not.
They control the investigation and Kellyanne
Conway saying, Oh, Trump, Trump wants everything
investigated.
Well, what about the allegations against Epstein
that relate to Trump?
Personally, including Mar-a-lago, including
party set up with dozens of young girls, were
the people part, planning the parties, thought
it was going to be some kind of big party.
It was just for Epstein and Trump, the allegations
against Epstein and Trump by the same 13 year
old girl.
Uh, what about investigating that?
If Donald Trump really wants everything investigated,
apparently they want everything other than
Donald Trump's many connections to Jeffrey
Epstein investigated.
And you know what?
They control the Justice Department.
They ultimately control the investigation.
They have oversight over the bureau of prisons.
This is how it works.
This is how a swamp filling corrupt cronyism
works.
And more than likely, we will not hear anything
else out of the administration that connects
Trump to this in any way because they're now
running the show.
Let me know what you think about what happened.
Let me know what you think about the Trump
connections.
Let me know what you think about what's going
to happen with investigations going forward.
I'm genuinely at a loss.
Uh, let me know on Twitter at d pacman.
Uh, you can follow the show on Twitter at
David Pakman show and while you're there,
please follow us on twitch, our newest platform,
twitch.tv/david Pakman.
I'll be streaming tomorrow, Tuesday evening
at 6:30 PM eastern time.
Hope that you will
join
me
there